Speaker 1: Well, ladies and gentlemen, if the
polls are to be believed, the Democratic Party may
be in the middle of a disastrous collapse, where
for the first time in a very, very long time, the
FiveThirtyEight Senate forecasts not the House.
The Senate forecast has by a very small margin,
Republicans now favored to take the Senate, as you
might remember, for a very long time. For months,
it looked like 2 to 1, even 3 to 1 odds that
Democrats would keep the Senate but probably
lose the House. Things have shifted and
shifted and shifted to the point where now,
if we are to believe the polling and we will look
at that in more detail, the most likely scenario
is Republicans definitely take the House and
maybe even take the Senate by a 52 to 48 margin.
Republicans now very slightly favored to
take the Senate. It's basically a dead heat,
but a far cry from the 70 plus percent odds that
Democrats had to keep the Senate just some months
ago. If we look at the FiveThirtyEight forecast
of how the odds have changed, you will see that,
yes, back in late July, it was basically 5050. And
then Democrats building, building, building a lead
all the way up to about a 71% chance of take of
holding the Senate in mid to late September and
a collapse to where now it is Republicans favored
to take the Senate over in the House. The numbers
even more dismal for Democrats now and 84% chance
that Republicans will win the House. If we look
at how those numbers have changed over time, you
similarly see that it was getting closer there for
a period in early October, still roughly a 2 to
1 margin for Republicans, but now just completely
out of reach. 84% chance, 84% chance for
Republicans of taking the House. One question that
many of you have asked. You came to me, some of
you, with tears in your eyes and said, Sir, can we
trust the polling? It is absolutely the case that
when you look at a lot of the generic ballots,
which aren't looking at individual races, but
these are generic Republican or Democratic support
in, for example, the House vote. It is true that
there are some right wing pollsters sprinkled in
Trafalgar, for example, which has Republicans
plus six. That's a right leaning poll. Rasmussen
is a right leaning poll and it has Republicans
plus seven, but many of what are considered
highly rated non politically partizan
pollsters also have Republicans leading,
but by a slightly smaller margin. CNN, NPR, Wall
Street Journal, CBS News all have Republicans
leading, but between two and four in that
congressional ballot. So the most important
thing to be asking is what is this mean for
what you should do? What does this mean for
what I should do? And it means that we should
vote. Just worry about you. You have one vote.
Make sure that you use it. I have one vote. I
will sure as hell make sure that I am using it.
And then in six days, six and a half days,
seven days, it will be Wednesday morning.
We will all have a very clear picture of where
this all shakes out. But I would be lying to you.
And I know every time whenever I do this, people
write to me and they say, David, you bastard!
You're discouraging people from voting by
saying Democrats have lost. Well, I'm not saying
Democrats have lost them, saying the polling is
looking increasingly bad. It's actually a reason
to vote. This should encourage people to vote. And
then when Democrats are leading and I report that,
people write to me and they say, David, you
bastard! You're going to make Democratic voters
complacent where they'll say, Hey, we've got it.
We don't need to vote. And no, no matter what
I'm telling you, we should all vote. But there
are some really bad looking numbers. Oregon,
for example, there has not been a Republican
governor in Oregon or Oregon, as the former
president likes to say. Oregon hasn't had a
Democratic a Republican governor since 1987.
That's like 100 years, roughly. Think
of that. We now have a Republican
gubernatorial candidate in Oregon that
is favored to win, not by a crazy amount,
but slightly favored to win. Now let's address a
couple of issues related to this. First of all,
I get right wingers. I see them on the YouTube
comments. I see them on my Twitter. I see them
on Twitch. And they are very much up
in my email gloating as if I personally
have some particular stake in this that
nobody else has just because I have a program.
I'm going to tell you guys this again. I will
do better in terms of my business and my show
if Republicans win everything, so much like you
all were coming to me in 2016 and gloating about
Trump, and much like many of you were coming to
me in 2020 and saying Joe Biden's going to lose,
which, by the way, you were wrong about. I don't
know what these folks are really gloating about
because I have my one vote. I have no special
extra votes just because I do a show. And again,
I want what's best for the country. What's
best for my business is that Republicans
win everything all the time. And Trump comes
back and they take the House and they take the
Senate and they take everything. Okay, I don't
want that. But the gloating is kind of weird
because it's just neither here nor there.
That's number one. Number two, why is this
happening? We have a combination of things. One
again. I just tell things the way I see them.
Democrats are terrible on messaging, just
absolutely terrible. Democrats have mostly ignored
since the Roe v Wade decision what we know. Year
in and year out are important economic concerns
and have minimized them to a great degree. Now on
my show, I just give you the numbers and I say,
hey, you know what? Extremely low unemployment,
nearly full employment. Inflation is high,
but it's flattening and it will come down. I just
give you the numbers. Right. But I'm not running
a campaign. Democrats went in a little too hard on
Roe v Wade as the defining issue of the election.
As I told you over the summer, the timing may
not actually work. The importance of Roe v Wade
as repeal may fade by November 8th. And indeed
that seems to be happening. And there is a lack
of a sort of escape hatch at this point for many
Democrats who have moved to the side. Some of the
some of the economic concerns now, a lot of those
economic concerns are based in misunderstandings,
like, for example, that the economy is a disaster.
The economy is doing pretty well. Gas prices down.
Unemployment very high. And job creation high.
But what matters is the perception of the economy.
And by hammering on it. Republicans may
have made significant headway in addition to
that. Typically, the party that wins the White
House gets crushed. In the following midterms,
it looked like maybe 2022 would be an
exception. But things are reversed are
coming back to it's a regression to the mean
you might call it historically. It should be
a bad election cycle for Democrats. So that's
the combination of what's going on. We will have
the real numbers very soon, but if we're going
to lose, I want to lose fairly. And that means
no armed intimidation of voters at the drop
boxes. And we've got to talk about that next.